[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
um
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
is my
camera broken
[Music]
[Music]
hello everyone
uh well i'm
completely uh
i don't understand why my camera is
missing
let me just quickly mess around in obs
but thank you so much for joining us
we're gonna be showing off uh some death
loop we're gonna be playing the early
couple hours of the game
um and i am joined by
the man
the myth the legend
there we go let me
uh
hello
mm-hmm
um
um
yeah yeah
mm-hmm
uh
gonna dunk on you
hard and publicly i'm so so sorry i
think i've had you mute it this whole
time
say something
hello everyone yeah yeah there you are
sweet
uh i cannot hear the game audio but i've
got it on mute so i don't i don't need
to hear the game audio i don't want to
hear myself or you oh cool now my voice
is echoing
so
it's because the camera audio
is is on probably
yes you're right try that now
that should be okay i've turned off
camera audio that's a good fix obs is
still very very new to me can you hear
cam can you hear game audio now there
should be stuff in there now
yep i can i can hear everything now okay
so you can hear game audio
i can okay
do you have the right mic picked
uh it's coming in through discord which
is why we're good now we're good we're
good all right
sorry everyone we should probably clip
this to make it look like we i mean
tammy actually does a lot of streaming
i'm very new at it um i'm going to be
playing today but tam
uh you tell me the spiel all over again
now that you've rehearsed it but i love
it i think they actually heard it i
think i actually heard it so i think we
should be good it was you that was the
problem it was you all
along
all right well
hang on
yeah
so uh yeah you can treat this as kind of
like an ama basically
uh the game audio is a bit quiet
apparently but
um we can raise that slightly but you
don't want it too loudly because it's
going to absolutely pop off and then you
probably won't be here
everything okay everything's good okay
sweet so yeah a little bit of um
explanation from my side so i finished
the game
i'm currently playing on my
fake account
uh because there's there's two lucy
james accounts this one's my american
account um
so some of the trophies i've already
popped because i did replay a little bit
but i have reset the loop completely so
this is going to be from a fresh game
i've put subtitles on the one thing that
i have done is i've turned off the
uh controller
micro uh the controller speaker because
juliana actually speaks to you a lot and
the way that the game does it is they
put it through this and i figured that
might not be the best experience for
when you are watching a stream so it
should um fingers crossed come through
the actual game on the call with me is
tam who from the game
lma
uh
and yeah any questions that you might
have for me as i'm playing if there's
something that you want to explore that
i am nearby to put it in the chat and
time will call it out or if you have
questions for tam as the reviewer please
uh feel free and like time said earlier
let's not do the whole oh exclusivity
game pass playstation oh xbox studios
i do not want this is not daycare we're
not here to take care of children we're
here for we have to answer the question
of gamers i'm here to talk about death
loop so um without further ado i'm going
to start up and uh let's get into it
let's get rolling should be um a little
uh opening cut sequence i'll get rid of
me
for the last time i can't remember never
no if you just give me a second
no you're not even trying
oh lady i have no idea oh
[ __ ]
you just hurry up already
that was one
ridiculous name
oh i got to snap drinking
okay
how the [ __ ] did i get
here back um all right let me turn down
the game just a little bit just while
we're talking and stuff so
welcome to black reef
uh this is the beach that you kind of
wake up on every day but the game
actually does a very clever thing in
that you don't wake up and see that
exact sequence every single time you
loop because otherwise that would be
incredibly repetitive um
break the loop
you gotta be kidding me
nope that's there i'm seeing it ah
man
uh yeah so be incredibly impressive so
the beach that makes you stay on the
same age
i should focus
oh
okay
the old dual sense is uh kind of going a
bit wild with it because
i mean can you hear this can you get
some dual sensation but like
it is uh quite hefty on the old haptics
uh one thing i will say is that like of
all the games i played on playstation 5
it um it definitely uses the haptics the
most i would say like even when i'm
walking down these stairs it's like each
footstep is going um and so that for
that reason i play with my ps5 dual
sense plugged in
okay yeah it feels like i uses the dual
sensor really well i think um it does
use it a lot but never aggressively like
it's a lot of subtle things here and
there like i didn't find myself being
distracted by it at all and it really
helped enhance some of the
combat um a lot of the combat as well
actually
um yeah but yeah so this is kind of like
colt's little sort of
base of operations i guess you would
call it um this is where you wake up for
the first time on black grave and as you
can tell he's done the great thing of
getting a map these are all the
visionaries that he's got uh to to take
out and uh you know he's gotten the full
uh
charlie from it's always sunny with it
but this guy is my one of my favorite
things in the entire game
black reef
must be the low season
pacquiaoki this i think
like hello i i have a real thing about
protagonists who talk like i find in
some games i think it's so overbearing
and it just like doesn't work but with
cults
just
yes i forgot the code yeah just like
it's so funny it's like it's very simple
referential of course like the whole
game is quite meta in a way but like he
says things that and in the delivery of
it like the voice acting is just so it's
gotta be unbelievably good kick ass or
anything else
um that it just like it doesn't get on
my nerves which is
very high praise coming from me if you
know any of my like big bug bears when
it comes to games but
hey
it helps that culprit generally talks to
himself
or he's a lot of his voice acting
is in the early parts of every loop so
this basically this mod
as you're leaving the tunnel
out in the world is very minimal um so i
i've played this game i've played this
opening like i think four times now i've
never once made this jump so
yeah it is it is kind of weird you have
to jump lazy
uh richard ziegler asks how is
performance on ps5 consistent fps i
don't have any issues with frame rate
and this is currently running at 30 fps
yeah yeah we're streaming at 30 because
uh
it's taxing on internet connections and
one of the best places
[Music]
yeah
but i never had any issues with uh frame
rate or visual bugs it's it's a very
polished game
um
the only time i had something happen was
one menu bugged but yeah it was it was
fine like it wasn't a major issue for me
it didn't really disrupt anything
um otherwise it's a very very like uh
clean game in terms of um technical
performance yeah i mean there's the
occasional um visual bug
and sometimes you'll get maybe
an ai bug every so often but like
it's wonderful otherwise like in terms
of how it runs like
i haven't had a single crash yeah i
genuinely didn't have any visual or like
stuff like
anything that no i noticed anyway so
i mean your mileage may vary as with
everything but um
it was all cool for me
oh
here's the lads
so
i'm surprised about the whole thing i
kind of enjoy
mocking people
that's one cool thing that you can do if
you hold down
the down button on the playstation
controller you can if you tap it you
mark someone but if you hold it down it
will tell you what weapon they have and
their general tendency like it will be
like incredibly aggressive so you know
how that enemy is going to behave when
you alert them like this guy another
snitch [ __ ]
uh yeah over here we've got
stop moving
cheap aggressive bastard unaware of your
presence down the kit and then
just do the [ __ ] radio you know
yeah you get the hakama jig very early
on and it's kind of like
the whole
first hour or so of the game i think
it's just a very
clever tutorial that kind of
like encourages you to mess around with
the game because that's you know where
arcane games really shine is when you
mess around don't go over there no
oh wait
uh captain
captain frantic says is this game fire
chocolate time travel no
this is like this has definitely got me
crazy
but like it's very fun it just feels
really nice to play because
when you do mess up a stealth section a
little hazy it doesn't feel as
yeah i think so
look if you don't try to break the loop
i'm just going to kill you over and over
again in increasingly violent ways until
you die
i'll break your [ __ ] loop and
whatever i did to piss you off i'm sorry
uh
still there you never said that before
we dated didn't just go inside the
library you need to see this
all right
no so um yeah so in dishonored it feels
like
if you
messed up or got seen you'd kind of like
that run would be over and you would
either want to i mean in dishonored 2
you could kind of quick start from the
quick load and quick save from the many
oh hello
oh i could i could dual wield
i never really draw it in this game but
you can do it um
whereas in this one it kind of feels
like it goes in and out of like all
like
guns blazing to not
very very quickly i can't get in there
yeah what are you doing uh jonathan
smith and youtube says is there a big
difference in gameplay between the death
loop uh
yes or no um wait what the game
one of them things about dishonored is
you kind of define a playstyle in a lot
of ways through the powers you pick
um and generally you're funneled down
that path which means you
are cut off from the other path whereas
this game is more about experimenting
constantly and switching up your play
style and kind of adapting on the fly
and because of that it's you get more
you
interact with more of the game
um
you can still play uh the game stealth
and you can still play uh all out guns
but there's no like morality system that
kind of stuff it's it's a similar game
but very different yeah all right
oh
[ __ ]
oh you always fought for the same old
[ __ ] just once please
try your hardest to make this
interesting
what the [ __ ] is this
you're gonna give me that attitude you
know i usually make it easy for you you
ungrateful prick but
this time i'll let you see yourself out
[Music]
yep we dated
why are you doing this
what did i do to you
and like going back to these sort of
opening areas i'm very intrigued to like
what i can and what i can't do um and
how the game kind of like i said the
first hour or so was very much
encouraging you to mess around
places but over there this is kind of a
nice moment so over there you can kind
of see
um
i did the reload animation but like
you can see sort of where you're about
to go which is very nice
but let's let's just do this instead
you you gotta be [ __ ] me
are you
listen to me
you wrote it on blackread you already
know the code what the [ __ ] does that
mean hello are you dead yet
hold me up
the postcard dumbass you wrote it on the
black reef postcard you understand okay
i'm gonna draw you now no wait the [ __ ]
i
[Music]
sort of like decided to break but you
know what we'll work with him all right
so again woke up
[ __ ] i like big old [ __ ] you died uh
you're back here again
but this time around you've got a little
same morning
same [ __ ] that's what this game is about
just getting a little bit more
information every time
[Music]
do you think the invasions will be
unbalanced on full release i don't think
so uh you also have the ability to turn
off the invasions to a degree you can
just set it to be single player you can
still get juliana invasions but there
will be ai
instead of actual players so you can
control the invasions to a degree
so one thing as well that i'll say is
all of the codes are randomized
[Music]
randomized for each player for what
you're seeing here
so what you're seeing here
how long it takes for that little circle
to fill but uh yeah
and then here this little uh this little
spot
gives you a sort of um
uh
i'm looking at chat and just to
reiterate if you're being uh
disruptive i'm just gonna time you out
so
jg you are done
why would someone put
this whoa
what the [ __ ]
what
okay
it's cold and weird
so this one here is colt's um
cult slab reprise which is an incredibly
useful one because obviously as you okay
if you go through all four kind of
times of day and you can only have one
life that's going to be very very tricky
so with reprise you can die um twice and
you kind of rewind a little bit you'll
be invisible when you come back
but that third death uh you are gone um
and then as well
the other good thing about it is that i
think it resets in between uh in between
whenever you go to a new area or any
time of day
and this is kind of like the the cool
part of death loop like it's building
blocks a little bit where these are all
the things that i discovered and even
though like i'm just playing the game
and i kind of like oh yeah that happened
the game keeps track of it all and it's
like gently leading me towards my new
thing so my next thing i'm going to do
is i'm going to go to uptown
yeah
going back to the reprise the really
cool thing is like there's so many
things in this game that are decisions
they make that when you think about it
are very very very smart when it comes
to design the reprise thing is um
you get basically three chances to do
something and because you get three
chances
it encourages you to a bit more be a bit
more experimental and bold like there's
a bunch of scenarios you can go into
where you're like i'm not quite sure how
to figure this out and i
and i ordinarily you might just sit
there and kind of like be paralyzed by
what to do whereas in this game you can
be like you know what i'm just gonna try
poking at different things and see what
happens run through the front door with
guns blazing see how everyone reacts see
if there's any like vantage points that
you can spot and then when you die you
reverse back and the enemies are going
to be on alert for a little bit but
you've got enough distance and you've
rewound back that you can now come at it
with that new knowledge
and tackle it in a more considered way
the one thing that you have to remember
is you will need to if you want to get
all your resources back your residue
which is a key resource
yeah i think abdom is my favorite as
well because it's like it also reminds
me a lot of dishonored yeah it's it's
definitely the one that's the most um
um
and yeah like i said i am way more a
dishonored player than i kind of
shoe-ishy fun time player so
that's kind of the approach that i'm
going to be taking
stick to the
stick to the roof
remember if you have any big questions
burning questions just chuck them in the
chat and i'll do my best to read them
out and we can try and
chat about them
does single players still
need an internet connection no single
player doesn't need an internet
connection
uh if you are if you are offline though
i believe juliana won't invade you
completely
all right
so it's it's way so like we're we're
here up down in the morning at different
times of day different people will be
here
like um this
this is always here for example but over
here there might be a turret or there's
usually maybe a kind of guard sentry up
here
and so sometimes it's fun just because
the enemies lay traps who they think are
for you but then you can just turn them
against them and i'll i'll show you
something a bit because that's my
favorite thing to do which is kind of a
lot of what i did it with prey
um
i very much
uh would just sort of
go another tech route and uh
and like invest in turrets and things so
here's like one of those it's just like
an open door it's like a mystery there's
a part of it it's a weird sort of like
autoerotic asphyxiation game as far as i
can tell where it's like hey you know
we're all gonna
do this pact of smoke thing here's my
code and then it's like you know it just
gives you these little breadcrumbs to
start these mysteries and
there you go
yeah um uh but this isn't duncan
yeah
duncan heart asks can i play it as an
fps you can yes yes you will
you can it will be trickier um because
uh
colt doesn't have a lot of health
especially to begin with and bullets do
the damage um you can augment that
um you just you just need to basically
uh you can play it as a first person
shooter but to mitigate the fact that
cult is kind of squishy you need to be
very intelligent and strategic with how
you use your powers and make sure that
your loadout is on point yeah because as
well i mean
the loadout building that over time is
who
very
important
is right um
but like i'm good i think as well the
bullets you don't carry a lot um and so
it's not that the game is trying to
actively
disencourage you and encourage
not encourage you to um to play that way
but
um it just means that like
bullets are rare and you have to think
about your environment and go around and
try and find places this though is my
favorite gun in the game
oh hell yeah
um the nail gun
or
like the whites kids you know thing
nail gun which i said every single time
i pick it up um
it's basically the silence pistol yeah
it's very very good so like as well
going through it um
not only do you kind of meet visionaries
and you know have these conversations
with juliana you can
read their chat logs um and kind of you
know just see how they act amongst
themselves so they also all have like
code names so alpha book alpha wolf 69
is alexis and alexis is just a real pain
in the ass
um
and charlie is just like a kind of
very nerdy guy who's just like
desperately you know wants to play his
games and stuff and the way they all
interact is really cool and over
archiver which is a very good pun is uh
is julian on it and uh
you see people all the time this is
where it's like
oh more messages have appeared
so like charlie is like one step ahead
of you there i mean like i'm just
showing this because it's uh you know
first day you can play the game like you
can just ignore that and just like
exit the level normally or you can do
what i did and mess up and kind of have
this little um this fight sequence
um so yeah here's the game telling you
that you can decide to
hang around if you want to
[Music]
having double jumpers like
a sort of default freebie um ability
that they give you is uh is very
underrated as well because it's yeah
it's the best one
i love it oh this is like the one place
i can never get up
there we go
i will never be a speedrunner at this
rate
um
yeah
all right let's just piss off this one
and so then the way that uh cult travels
is through these tunnels
run underneath this and that's my auto
filled code that's how i'm getting this
play
any idea how this will run a two to four
year old pc that's going to do was
terribly optimized can't say we played
the playstation 5 version um
yeah i
really can't say it
i did see that to get like the ultimate
ultimate um
slickest version you do need quite a
beefy pc but
if you i mean i imagine like how to can
i run this or something would be able to
clue you in a little bit more there
because yeah we both played vbs5
and so now
it's noon
um and so
you'll kind of notice that it's very
tutorial heavy um because obviously
there's a lot of interlocking systems
that you kind of have to understand and
so the previous time we came to that
menu it was like here's how to do your
loadout here's how to change time or
whatever um
and so you'll find that a lot at the
very beginning but then it completely
easier you're gonna call me like this
all the time julie juliana i give
approximately zero [ __ ] about what you
call yourself well you did once i used
to be friends
oh so that's why you told everyone to
kill me but i'm the only one talking to
you so what does that tell you that i
hang out with the wrong people all right
control center
so yeah clearly big things are happening
over here in a minute
big things
okay so there's a there's a tower over
there let's go have some fun
i do like this area too
it's a little trickier because of the
crates the cargo containers
which often have people hanging around
on top of them
[Music]
which is very very handy if i don't feel
like getting my hands down
[Music]
favorite bit
can i chuck it
[Music]
the amount of
awful situations i've set up for
uh different enemies and visionaries
using current movable turrets is a lot
of fun in this game
see she's uh
she's on edge
oh she died that's why
i think the weird thing about me for me
when i was playing deathly for the first
time is like trying to understand what i
can and can't interact with
um so like here for example that's
residium but i can't interact with that
just yet but it's also like stuff in the
environment like you can't
mess around with any of that but then
the stuff that you can mess around with
and interact with and use to set up
traps and things
is it gets quite useless she's glowing
she's glowing
um
because
she's quite a powerful
uh enemy
killer she should have some better
trinkets and maybe even a weapon
so
well not good ones but
i'm gonna replace
okay onwards
i can also set up traps with this with
the grenade which is quite funny i
finished the game without ever knowing
that the grenade could transform because
i completely skipped the tutorial
because i was like oh i don't need to
read a tutorial about a grenade but yeah
it's also a trip mine and a proximity
charge so um
pay attention to tutorial menus
okay so now it's basically
your predator room
some people uh nemo says some people
have commented on the ai seeming a bit
basic is that overblown
um i don't think the ai is basic there's
a i feel like personally this is my
perspective as someone who's played it a
lot there's a really delicate balance to
strike when it comes to creating ai you
want them to be challenging and you want
them to pressure you but you can't make
them too small or too clever in a game
where
your ultimate goal is to build momentum
because if every ai
uh enemy was a brick wall for you to
fight like it's some sort of dark souls
enemy you'll never be able to build the
right rhythm you need to get into the
flow state for this game so in the ais
are challenging if they see you they
will attack you and they will be
aggressive if you're hiding in the
distance or on a roof they will throw
things at you they will lob grenades at
you
they will they will get in your face um
and they are very very resilient at
times as well however they're not gonna
they're not super super super
challenging it's not gonna be like a
long fight with each of them what they
make up for
what they lack in power they make up for
in numbers and in kind of like
resourcefulness
but for me they strike the ai strikes
the right kind of balance between being
challenging and stopping you when they
need to and also being
squishy and killable to the point where
you don't feel like you're being held
down and you're being like shackled with
you know some sort of weight that you're
constantly struggling it's not an uphill
struggle that's not the point of this
game the whole point is you're supposed
to feel like you're quickly building
momentum because the whole point is
you're trying to get through this day
and kill everyone in one swift uh kind
of
journey down here trying to think there
is a guy
now
is there a limit to how many weapons you
can carry yeah you can carry two slab
abilities and then i believe it's one
two
three weapons three
yeah three weapons
um
yeah because reprise counts as one of
your slap weapons so
this is my
dishonored
playing uh in action but i like to just
sort of like to watch
and just let them do their own thing oh
don't go around that side i set up the
trap there
oh no
[ __ ]
[Music]
there we go okay
gotta be a switch
around here somewhere
if an enemy alert
does
if an enemy gets alert it does every
anyway get loaded or just enemies in
certain radius certain radios depend no
well it depends who you are yeah who
yeah there's some enemies who are
a little more loud and have the ability
to alert more enemies yeah so they
um
there are some enemies that have um
little radios and they'll radio in for
backup but what you can do is you can
hack them
um to stop that happening
oh you gotta be kidding me batteries so
if you enjoyed whale oil
boy this is the mechanic for you
um
there's only like there's a few of these
dotted around like uh having to find
batteries to power things but there's
one uh sequence in particular that um
that requires it so
it's good that it's okay
juiced show me what you can do
i'll have to do the lever again
welcome eternalist this is igor sterling
have you ever wondered how our beloved
time loop functions long ago the island
black grief experienced a cataclysmic
experience
of space and time and that's what we
call this
study the again imbalances of this
phenomenon and thus
uh
you
must protect and study us
visionaries
follow the three tenets
uh
so there are like the tunnels that come
in and out of the uh in and out of each
area they kind of like there's like one
of two exits and so frequently you'll
find that it doesn't try and encourage
you to like
you know go out this way for a change
try this also ammunition's free
you just have to remember where a uh a
deeper is i guess not deeper but like a
machine for it
i've seen a bunch of people in chat
saying this game is pretty much
dishonored without parkour
oh no i just don't have the abilities
for that yet
yeah that's incorrect there's you can do
i mean if you're trying to be reductive
get a grip that's not what this game is
um
look with your eyes and think with your
brain i'm sure you'll see how it's
different
um but no there's way more to it than
what you're seeing on screen currently
how long is the game it depends on how
you approach it like you can complete it
generally i'd guess between
12 to 15 hours for most people yeah
if you i i completed it in 12 i think um
but if you're super methodical which i
do recommend um it's on the higher end
yeah i mean i was talking to other
people who were playing and um
matt burslow at ign was like i finished
the game and then i spent 10 hours
afterwards beyond i mean this was last
week so he's probably spent more than
that just trying to uncover every secret
um and trying to get all the answers so
it's it's
like dishonored it's like you can finish
it very very quickly if you want to but
if you want to uncover every life secret
and there are tons of them in this game
then it's that's up to you
[Music]
i'm quickly gonna mess around with my
loadout
smart you have to be doing that a lot
because where am i going
free shed rock afternoon
this one if i recall is quite a uh
yeah
oh no did it get rid of the other i got
rid of my shotgun because i couldn't
carry it
it's here bugger oh now i'm stuck with
the rapier i shouldn't have
you know what we're fine we'll
we'll be fine i get i got more chances
so you can see you can customize weapons
here by adding trinkets to them which
change how they perform
you get a variety of buffs ranging from
like range to power to speed of reload
that kind of stuff
and you get trinkets for coal as well
yeah
so that's where the customization comes
in emil flores who's asking in the chat
um you can change things like how
quickly he runs how much noise he makes
how his health regenerates as uh
hopefully ease regenerates if you're out
of power
really are oh yeah easy i'm a drinker
occasionally a drunk man about island
everyone knows me everyone hates me
handy with a gun quick with a joke i
dress well and why the [ __ ] is everyone
wearing a mask
security officers a hot minute
always take the high ground
always
vantage is good
they all pee a lot
yeah i feel like i'm always catching
them uh
yeah so i feel like i never dual wield
in this game because i'm always like i
always have a power equipped like you
always have shift or ether
um
so this bit yeah like
if you come here earlier in the day this
is not snowy at all
um
don't look at me
don't look at me
[Music]
don't look at me
joke to joke ask how will speedrunners
play this can it be done in one shot um
yes it can i think like some of the most
interesting parts of this is gonna be
how speedrunners figure it out and get
to it because
you can really really min max movement
and abilities and
get it done very very fast if you know
what you're doing and you've got the
dexterity and
timing for it am i sliding is that why i
can't get up there i usually would get
up there um
interesting all right uh yeah i mean
this is the game that basically
encourages you to speed on it
um
like by the time you've built up your
sort of roots and best ways to approach
each
visionary you you get such a good lay of
the land that you
definitely
just kind of immediately built that
proficiency
[Music]
so i don't have sound so i can't tell if
that turret hears me or not um
[Music]
oh
no
there's people here
this is what it's all about
figuring out different times of day
these people are not here
yeah
come on
oh
[Music]
if you knew exactly what to do yes
um it would be trickier because you
wouldn't have a lot of abilities
or weapons but it is doable
um
don't don't attack my turret
see they're all looking like
there we go
do in-game choices matter in your
playthrough or is it a straightforward
story
um i don't i wouldn't say your choices
are
like you're not making choices that are
going to diverge the story
um but it's not a straightforward story
it's told in it's a weaving story where
you'll get pieces of there's multiple
arcs running concurrently between
characters and
visionaries and
the world itself how the history of the
world and it doesn't just tell you all
in one big law dump you find pieces of
it reference to it and kind of put the
pieces together yourself
and so it's a very kind of uh
natural way of learning about the game
and and having a story delivered to you
as opposed to an exposition dump yeah
i mean i think yeah cult waking up
amnesiac with a hangover israel
[Music]
[Music]
she's killed anyway
i thought i would have to deal with it
[Music]
um
and i can't remember if there was
another guy up here that is on another
loop
yeah
area cleared
um
uh pierre asked does juliana interrupt
the game in set locations slash moments
or can it happen literally anytime uh as
long as there's a visionary in the map
you're in she can pop up pretty much
anytime yeah but it's usually
pretty near there like just as soon as
you've not just as soon as you got in
but like in the first few minutes of you
being in a um
in a place i felt really bad because i
invaded someone
and they were
we will show you the map very very
shortly
um
they were killing a bunch of people that
they needed to and just before they were
about to kill the final person i killed
them
[Music]
it really it really lets you be a
complete ass if you are in an invading
juliana which i really enjoy
so i'm not always the best at it but
still
when you want to be an [ __ ] you can
be i'm harriet
you can be but if you're being an
[ __ ] in our chat i will ban you so
dark death 47 you're on the list careful
with what you say second five
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i really hate the snowman don't you well
i
haven't looked fully at the trophy list
but i wonder if there was a trophy
i don't think so
and it has a very good slide
which i pretty much enjoy using
okay
uh not jump to come but i know you just
started story again i saw there was
online pvp will you be showing that
later on
can do
yeah we can we can do some pvp later on
i have to do a certain
number of missions on this side
um
before i'm late i'm
like
set out in the world
maybe i'll do pvp on my other account
where i have a bit more um
i have more trinkets and weapons and
stuff because otherwise i'm gonna get
absolutely smoked
on this side
if i do it on this one
it might be good to do do it from
scratch because it will show the
progression as well yeah
that's true and also there's no
expectation for you to be amazing at it
playing a game on the internet tomorrow
i mean
all right backing up dom juliana
juliana you there
juliana
i love the way they just like
poke at each other
i appreciate the uh naughty by nature
reference thank you
okay
hope so
oh is this streams uh getting cut short
is this the best use of wall tech since
when it's a conviction i think so
yes absolutely
okay yo
i normally come down here in the day and
she's not there
folks asking about pc performance we
can't really answer that question we
played it primarily on
es5
how replayable is this game is there a
new game plus mode fcb well
replayability is kind of the point of
the entire game like you're replaying
the days are you replaying
parts of the game over and over until
you've got it down to a tee
um once you're done with it once you
have the final loop you're kind of like
you can um
you're put in a place where uh you're
just before going on the final loop and
you can carry on prolonging the session
the loops until you want to until you're
ready to decide to take it on and then
after you're done with that it kind of
puts you back in the world just before
you attempted your final loop so there
is replayability in there but there's
not a new game plus mode to any extent
to this traditional extent because that
wouldn't work with the way that you get
powers and abilities and stuff like that
in this game yeah
[Music]
i think she's
she's wrong so
rate the deal sense on a scale of hog
nods to rich d biscuits
wait alien man 420 i don't like this
scale scale you've put hobnobs you've
said hobnobs which is makes me think
that you put that on the low end with
rich tea biscuits on the high end which
is the inverse of how it should be if
we're saying on the scale of rich tea
biscuits to hobnobs it's absolutely hot
i might even say it's chocolate covered
hobnob
rich tea is
is just blind rich tea is like the
biscuit that's in your cupboard
in your mom's cupboard that you like
never want
yeah
you can't tell you could leave it out
and it could go stale and you'd eat it
and you'd be like yep that's just a
normal rich day
you can't tell when it's bad but uh
alien man has said no my bad i see oh
yeah i thought so no worries no worries
alien man knows what's going on it's a
it's a
hobnob oh kelsey's here and kelsey's
dropped in chocolate covered molten milk
which is an s ranked fish that is a
unbelievable bit that is kelsey knows
what's up
hey kelsey
oh
see the thing is it's like
i just i feel like i just
i know where stuff is i know where
people are gonna be
and it feels really good
but also
any i can i can mess up at like a
moment's notice just because of just the
nature of the game a teachable moment i
wondered if this was a reference to bean
dad
um
because bean dad happened in the year
2021 of all things because this year has
felt like five years long but yeah
is this a puzzle shoot
to a degree it's not a puzzle shooter in
the sense that you are
you know completing puzzles like this
the way it's a puzzle shooter is you're
looking at the world around you and
looking at the marks that you are
given as an assassin and figuring and
you're puzzling out the best way to kill
all of them in one run
so
it's a puzzle game but not in the
traditional sense of a puzzle game
you're not going to be solving logical
puzzles you'll be solving situational
kind of like you're doing situational
analysis and figuring out what tools you
have at your disposal and the best way
to use them
you're not assassinated you're not using
a uh i'm not doing it
no
so here we have a juliana ai invasion
lucy needs to hack this
[Music]
yeah so that if you don't hack that the
tunnels are locked so you can't escape
what have she got she's got
i did
check it for a slab
so juliana usually the visionaries can't
carry the slabs that give you powers but
juliana also has powers slab powers so
you can sometimes get them from her
instead of um
getting them from the visionary which
makes things slightly easier no people
ask me people are saying if we can turn
the game volume down a bit down a bit
sure
let me know if that's okay if not i will
adjust a bit more so now we've got
shift
which is my favorite it's like
now that i have shift i feel like i can
breathe again i can breathe
um
it works exactly the same way it works
in dishonored uh dishonest blink so yeah
you see it even does the same
triangle thing to kind of tell you that
you're gonna land on top of something
but now shift is uh
ah shift is a lifesaver and i don't have
any trinkets to make my power usage
lower or
any of that so i will be using it
sparingly
we've got the one and at least bland
gamer steve in chat he says hello
friends uh quick question does the game
give you help or direction on what you
should be doing next or does it drop you
in and be like good luck i'm afraid this
will feel overwhelming with the amount
of choice well steve uh you'll be happy
to hear that it gives you a lot of
direction it's actually a good middle
ground i found i think lucy can show off
the two specific menus that are in the
game that will guide you into what to do
i think
when i get out of here yeah when you get
out you should be able to so there's two
menus basically there's
effectively there's a menu that is leads
designed specifically to get you the
information you need to kill the
visionaries and then there's a separate
one that is designed to be your arsenal
lead which is like this is all the stuff
this is where all the cool weapons and
abilities are and this is what you need
to this is the path you need to take to
get that stuff so steve it won't be
overwhelming the thing that about it is
it has those like hand-holding leads but
as well as that there's loads of things
hidden in the environment that you are
left there for you to discover in a very
natural way yeah so the part of the loop
is picking something and going i want to
try and get this or i want to try and do
this and then the game will put it on
the map for you right and always have
the waypoint for you to save yeah and as
well like before you've got notes
written all over the island
literally in some cases but also like
notes to pick up but the two
um
what weapons are going on like the two
menus that i should be able to get to
once we're in once we're through this
are very very helpful and yeah like time
like time said it's um
you can kind of set your own objectives
from within there and so it's like if
you want to go to
carl's bay and you don't
it's actually quite helpful like
especially the first time you're doing
something i find it's like it's very
forgiving
got my trusty knife
and my slab
all right hit the apartment hard
get the safe so you know it's like
seeing that it's like the first few
times i'm running the loops i'm
basically going
to my apartment to freestyle and like
seeing them at different times of day so
you're kind of getting to learn the lay
of the land a bit but you're also
gaining more confidence in it which is
what i found really helpful at the
beginning because then at the point
where it says okay now you can go and do
into any area any time of day i felt
like i was like oh well i could continue
my
mastery in this place
or i can i can try something new so this
at the minute is very linear this is
like the um the visionary lead
until things split so once i finish this
quest the longest day it'll basically
give me one of these for every single
visionary so i can choose to go and
chase them down if i want to and these
are the discoveries i've made um just
along the way like about harriet is
responsible for eon's organizational
structure and the masks charlie runs the
minicom network and so these are small
pieces of information that might not
seem very useful right now but
later on um it will be and then
shortly i think after this mission
another one appears up here which is
arsenal leads which isn't like
how you track down who has which
um who has which slab or some really
cool guns that you can get in the
environment
um or like you can solve a mission to
get some really cool guns so
sure
uh steve also asks uh what's the balance
like in gunplay stealth i played this on
a very stealthy without killing anyone
but it seems like he's leaning on the
other way does the game encourage either
way of playing if that makes sense so uh
first of all if you're into a chat and
you don't follow a blind gamer steve
make sure you do that um done a lot of
amazing work out there for accessibility
follow me on twitter as well
um but yeah uh steve you can pretty much
play it how you want like i'm a pure
stealth gamer usually um i mention as
much in my review and it's very doable
it's a little trickier to begin with
because you have uh there's not a lot of
like you don't start with like shift or
blink as it were in um
dishonored but
you will very easily find your stealth
groove and obviously that requires a lot
more patience but as someone who plays
stealth you'll have no issues with that
um but then it's also like um
you can play it all out guns blazing and
it feels rewarding to do that the game
never pushes you in any direction um
there are kind of like generally certain
slabs that are better off so
you want to try and get shift you want
to try and get aether
as kind of like a kind of
basics for stealthing um and then from
there you're good those two basically if
you've got those you're good you've got
a solid foundation for stealthing
everything and then the nail gun you'll
very quickly um find in this specific
area of the game that lucy's in it's
like the first one you'll find the game
pushes you towards it that is basically
a silenced pistol um and those are the
three things that you need to stealth
this game
pretty much on a basic level but you can
definitely do stealth if that's what you
want to do man yeah i mean this this gun
like i said is my
uh it's my best friend
like
four pound is good
um but i never used it that much because
i i i liked this one as well the light
uh machine crystal oh right
and then yeah here's the lpp which is
basically like a list of where
so you get you get a basic understanding
of where all of the visionaries are
going to be
however you've kind of got to fit them
all in one
um this is how i'm going to work one
good pattern right
people one day and so that's kind of
where the visionary leads coming up oh
all right so so what's the plan eight
targets one day we're going to need a
couple more colts in here if we're going
to wreck this island in a culture
no listen i can't stay long how did you
even get in here uh adam lewis i told
everyone i have a zero tolerance policy
for look at fanboys
i don't know but none of us have gotten
it right okay you've got to be better
than all of us so don't just try to
shoot everything but i like shooting you
got to be smart look at this guy he's
beautiful
oh man the voice acting song
jacket i prefer the cold stone i i
wonder if they'll do it just go and easy
themselves
okay
so
now we're about to go and take out
a visionary
[Music]
uh so yeah now finish the longest day
finish that first mission
it's time
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls to
go take one of their environment
so ubiquity is like
this is a really really useful mission
because as you'll notice like every time
i wake up on the beach
i don't have anything uh with me
i'm
you know i i have my one
double jump trinket that it gives me and
then i pick up my gun my one gun i pick
up um
my hakuma jig and my grenades and then
other than that my
my arsenal is empty so this next mission
helps me retain things uh overloops so
that's what i'm gonna go do however is
not as straightforward as killing just
one person
huh
and the first time i did this one
i was so desperate to like do it right
and get and like
do it the full dishonored way
hmm
um
but now i've got a few more tricks i'm
very excited to tackle it
the loot preservation protocol
uh steve's asking uh is there a high
low chaos mode like in the sonnet nope
nope i know where there's none of that
but i'm guessing it won't be if you do
what you want to do
it's up to you [ __ ] i love those
little animations as well
so yeah this is like the end of it uh
end of the kind of handholding tutorial
thing that's like here you go you finish
this mission
now
here's all the cool weapons you can find
so here's like you should find residum
um or like figure out how to use it
um
and this is explaining
how the day night cycle works and
honestly it's like it's quite simple
there were four places there were four
times a day and this is how you move it
so i know that wengie
is in the afternoon so let me
do that
all right how how big is the map
it's
big depending on how you think of it
it's not one big map um there's four
different locations as lucy said day
night
and each area is pretty expensive um
you could think of it like four four
different districts uh of of a bigger
map that you travel between
um each one is super detailed super
teaming with um
things to do and see and
easter eggs and discoveries to find but
it's not one big connected open world
i am always succeeding even when i'm not
trying to tackle it uh
[Music]
you just you should go back and no i
can't because i'm trying to well i could
but i have to restart the day and i
wouldn't have this gun
you know what this is my fault so
you have to figure it out
yeah i'm trying to desperately double
jump but i don't have it this is my own
fault
i was just like oh just we don't get to
this next mission
all right
well in that case i guess it's a low
power
uh
okay ooh he's seen me as a race
this is this is single player you can
play the game offline if you want we're
currently playing in single player and
in single player the giuliana that
invades is going to be ai control
once you once you make it you can open
it up to have your friends available to
invade your game or you can open it up
to have anyone able to invade your game
it's your choice
if you disconnect from the internet
completely i believe
did time vanish for just me
no i'm here oh you vanished like right
at the end of your sentence um i'm not
sure if that was just for me
if you want to repeat it or not
i think i think people heard me i think
people heard me
um
oh i'm just too far away
so the thing about it is like
they've tried to do it so obviously in
dishonored uh
[Music]
and it's similar here like there's this
little sort of whisk that i've left
behind even like i've killed them
um even though they kind of vanish
there's still like whisper left behind
and that's why it's like oh sometimes
you know they'll walk around and they'll
notice that someone's died that's how
they don't leave the bodies around
um
but one thing that i
am going
to
um
so one thing i do is there is an upgrade
for ether that you can get which means
that if you kill anyone while you're
invisible their body fully vanishes that
is a game changer if you are a sneaky
sneaky boy or speaker
and the way to get upgrades for your
slab abilities
is to kill the visionary that has them
repeatedly every time you get that slab
again it instead appears as an upgrade
for your existing one
and you get a different enough different
number of upgrades depending on the
ability some have up to four some have
three etc etc
and so generally that's why that's how
they incentivize you to keep on killing
visionaries on repeated runs or juliana
will also drop them if you can kill her
welcome to my biggest bug bear in death
loop is that if you throw the turrets
sometimes they fall over and you can't
deploy them from afar which was my grand
plan there and uh i couldn't do it um
but it's okay because things uh things
worked out yet so
this woman
here
hopefully she has some good stuff
we've got tribunal oh okay
no don't place
can you run a gun or do you have to
sneak you can do whatever you want
i'm just a sneaky player
so always taking out all the uh turrets
and stuff just in case
um but yeah my my favorite card is the
nail gun
so
target a quiet
[Music]
so you can use the hacking jig through
um
through walls which are not through
walls with your windows which is very
very handy
is there a limit to how many turrets or
cameras you can hack to be on your side
nope not that i've once i i've not found
one no i've set up like four to five
turrets in a single area at once
it did work
that's my favorite sneaky thing to do is
um
[Music]
it's very good at tracking notes it's
very good at highlighting the
information yeah and it's very good at
making sure you know exactly what it
means it will summarize it and also put
it on your kind of like files for you to
look at as you're seeing on the screen
yeah so here are the three like
three of the visionaries that it
recommends you go get and then uh this
is me trying to find
wengie's research and then but in terms
of discoveries like tiny bits of
information
are changed by map and also by like
what's relevant on time of day as well
um
so yeah it does a really good job
it's all there for you to look at
there's also little audio logs you can
listen to
um
as well as notes in the environment and
there's like a bunch of secrets in here
already
um
like a crank wheel
and like there's wenges making our own
trinkets and stuff so you can
investigate that
so the visionaries drop better trinkets
and usually better weapons as well
so it is
very worthwhile just to do like a couple
of runs actually i might just grab this
turret and take it with me
just for life
can you lean around corners you can yeah
you just need to approach the corner and
then hit the uh aim down status button
and you're quickly leaning around corner
you do expose yourself though so you
can't
you're not invisible as you lean around
corners
things that you hack stay ahead
uh
okay well she's going over there i can
go over here
no don't look at me
don't
look at me don't see me
i should have set up my turret
no don't come this way
where did she go where'd she see that
okay
[Music]
um i saw another one go upstairs so
no steve you can't save scum can't save
something
like car safe's gone uh
and so that's why i'm like
desperately trying to do it
don't look at me don't look at me
[ __ ]
oh it's okay
we're okay
everyone
did she see me
is she coming for me
i think she is oh yeah she is quick
[Music]
oh
and then you'll kind of find that things
do
typically settle down a little bit like
they they think that they killed you
that the um
the trouble's over
trouble is just beginning where did i
leave that turret
okay so there's two wendy's over there
there's one to the other
okay tell us there
so that's my body
oh the turret the wenges have gone
uh
says my body
um
usually you could pick up the residual
from it but i haven't used
um
after this mission so
let's
try and go over here
kicking myself though actually can i
throw that
yeah tom hutchinson says it seems like
you don't start the whole level again
you do if you get killed the third time
third time yeah
ah okay there's a wengie so what i can
do
is um
okay
can i
you can chuck it down there and then
turn it on
the best place to chuck it
oh
do it right there but if it lands on its
side yeah that's that's my one fear
where it's like risk it risk it for it
i'm stuck
risk it for a digestive biscuit
we're good
eyes facing the wrong way no no is it
good is it good she's walking she's
walking
so
annoyingly i want to try and get like
see what i would have loved to have done
is have this set up
just so that when those two ran up they
would just run straight into my little
channel there's one there's one
visionary's place i'm not gonna spoil it
um but it is so set up for
just
tons of turrets
and
as someone who's previously played a lot
of symmetra in overwatch and just loves
making little
kill rooms
sorry
i feel bad but i'm sorry
grab some stuff
[Music]
so now
this is the reason we came here
to grab this to learn how to use residue
properly and use it across the day so
now i'm just going to finish killing
[Music]
you to get her machine ready that makes
sense yeah
all right
these two are quite annoying because
there's a turret and a um sometimes i
told you
yeah
you can some other one
in another scenario here chat chat
unacceptable
you can
use the nexus slab to link those two
wengies together and just kill one and
the other one would die
yeah so
visionaries um
take a few more bullets to kill
[Music]
yeah has this game got a hardcore mod
where you don't get the three death
safety net
no
no i think you always be reprised off
yeah you always have that i'll try i'll
try next time we're in the um yeah as
far as you know you're wrong
you can just make things harder for
yourself by not using any abilities or
not using any
um weapons for example yeah i mean i
don't think there's a similar thing so
obviously in dishonored you can refuse
the outsider's power
and
make your own hard mode that way but i
don't think you can do that all right
now just get in this tube shower thing
and uh suggest the button hoya once said
how the [ __ ] am i supposed to do
there are no difficulty modes in this
game
why all right science let's dance i will
easier
like if you want to you can
fully just reveal
[Music]
wow hayley atwell's gonna be in
a uh
tomb raider anime
something i didn't think
breaking news
according to the hollywood report
[Music]
so yeah
now though
now i've got residueum
and boy can we do some [ __ ] with residue
i can finally hold on to my precious
precious nail gun in between
in between rounds in between
it actually actually worked
i'm gonna do a point break
baby together before a celebratory point
break at least until i break this loop
so from here i think
this is the last time you actually wake
up on this because you're you're
starting to do your sort of normal
normal loops and normal loops will open
you up
pick a map
but in a minute because i've just got
residue it's like
suck it up baby
why does it feel like um and actually
when you when you start your normal
loops
and you've
the game like streamlines all this so
you've come through all here you've
picked up that trinket which is always
spring healed you've picked up your
hakama jig you've come through here
you've picked up your grenades and your
knife and your pre-slab and then and
then it puts you in the um your table
awaits in things you don't have to do
this uh the game just like streamlines
it for you which is very very helpful
and
spring hill colt miracle that's liberty
now that is
[Music]
so yeah so normally now when you start a
loop you'll wake up at this next screen
this next screen
uh is the game quite short uh
it's just eight targets like the one
lucy finished it no it's that wenge is
perhaps the easiest of the targets to
kill everyone else is quite complicated
and it's a matter of
that that target you can quite easily
walk up to not all the targets are the
same you need to figure out how to get
to them and that can take a little while
you have to solve some
light puzzles figure out the parameters
of what they're doing when they're doing
it what they're up to and
there's some situations where you might
have targets that are in two different
places at the same time making it
impossible for you to kill them at the
same time so you need to figure out a
way
of manipulating them to get them
in the same spot to make it easier for
yourself
so i'm gonna use i'll go on
someone else rahul asks uh
how does a save system work can we quit
and continue a loop later on or do you
need to finish it in one nope once
you're in a
map area if you quit you start at the
beginning of it um you need to there's
no saving inside a image so it's not at
the start of the loop like the whole the
whole day it's the start of that
particular area and that time of day so
if you put your playstation into rest
mode
um when you're in a mid run
careful with your automatic updates
always quit out i would say at this like
um
the loadout screen uh map screen so one
thing i'm just doing quickly here is i
am sacrificing a trinket that's pretty
useless but it means that i can now
afford to hold on to this gun
by infusing it with residue and that
means that that gun will stay with me
till the end of the game now uh it'll
just be in my arsenal and
one thing that makes like the risk
reward aspect of it very very cool
is that you have to do that with every
power you obtain as well and so usually
when you kill the visionary you get
enough residual
to
almost completely infuse that slab
and
uh
yeah it just means that sometimes you
can do a really good run
and
get whatever trinket or whatever you're
after and then you're like oh no wait uh
i died or i didn't infuse it and then
it's lost so it's definitely
something to keep in mind um
so i
you see we've got like 40 minutes 20
minutes left do we want to do some
julianna um okay so i'm on
[Music]
let's try it
because
i'm just saying that my internet on here
is maybe not that good because i'm on
the wi-fi on my
my playstation but i'm plugged in on the
uh
on the laptop but we'll try it
let's see yeah you're also streaming so
awesome streaming
please if you're watching keep in mind
that the internet is not particularly
great and it's already under a heavy
load so confused idiot who thinks he can
just destroy what we've built here same
so that part of the game is pretty good
regulations high alert battle stations
to be mandatory
you want
everyone to have
visionaries at your but now let's hop
into
this is pointless
multiplayer
i'm intrigued to see how many people are
going to be online
[Music]
um oh yeah also didn't show off much of
these but there are these very very cool
but there's
um
little arcade machines all around so
this is obviously
the doom one aka hell crasher but
there's also i've seen a couple of
dishonored ones um
they're very very
good morning black reef juliana blake
with an urgent announcement i have just
learned that colt has betrayed us we'll
be on high alert with restricted leisure
until he's dead
so
let's kill him quickly okay and remember
have a fulfilling day
watch out this one is smart
cunning even yeah but we're smarter
oh and have a fulfilling day i know
all right did you get given the deluxe
edition dlc to try and if so
how was it balanced wise
does the skin make it i don't think so
like the skins make no difference to
anything
there's nothing changes any sort of um
balance system in this game yeah i don't
think we did
um i think it's just the regular edition
okay
do we have
oh we've got
nexus [ __ ] all right do you have to kill
targets in any particular order no not
to begin with um you can pretty much
experiment how you want
you will eventually figure out an
optimal route for yourself though yeah
let me treat so i've i've applied
everything
um that i have currently it's like level
one uh so these are like feats that you
can do as juliana so like survive for a
certain number of time uh a certain
amount of time kill cult a specific way
um
or you know use specific things and so
by doing feats
feats mean prizes points being prizes
then you unlock
different weapons abilities
with giuliana you don't have to infuse
them
which is very good you just kind of get
them and add them to your arsenal you
also get new outfits so there's 12 to
unlock
and you can also unlock cult outfits
as well
good feet content
feet
um
but yeah i don't know how many people
are gonna actually be
playing so
we'll try it
let's see
i mean worst case scenario is i go on my
other account and we kind of
invade people from my friends list if
they're online
um
but yeah this is the the trials and
tribulations of playing a game
pre-release
and trying to use multiplayer
but we'll give it a we'll give it a bit
give it a solid wall
sometimes i like to just kind of quit
out and then go back in and usually yeah
kind of tries to find something but also
people should be at work at the minute
so
maybe if you're playing you are
snitching on yourself
unless you're in like a european time
zone and it's you know
almost 6 pm that's fine quitting time
sneaking a bruce forsyth reference into
the stream nice one
points means prizes points being prizes
i mean chat you tell us how long you
want to wait for folks on matchmaking
because like i said pre-release people
might not be playing
also
i'm just going to check my internet
i am definitely connected
yeah
let's have a look
yeah
i mean i don't have any friends on here
because this is my fake account
you should maybe switch to another um
screen do full screen before you move
around in the menus
[Music]
i'm trying to think what i could do
i don't have a scene set up
just do full screen on your camera if
you can
see
you know what
oh i could just do this
goodbye
fade to black
so i don't accidentally expose my
location on the internet network stock
on the internet i am connected to the
internet we're good
yeah
[Music]
don't worry about it everyone we're back
i'm back and connected to the internet
uh yeah i don't think people are to be
online unless like
time is your playstation next to your
uh next to your pc no i can't i can't
play and be on stream at the same time
sadly
just carry on with the single player
eric and then all right oh wait i found
one
you got one
[ __ ] now
i'm gonna have to
be okay at playing
uh unknown error you're getting banned
goodbye
no sexist jokes thank you i thought you
were talking about me
you're getting banned
okay
[Music]
oh
god okay
and the reason i say oh god is because
oh first of all i've got [ __ ] weapons
uh and also this is like
quite a tough one
yeah this one
what am i doing
oh he's over there okay so he's actually
not that far away as juliana i can i
guess this makes us teammate
another
i have another eternalist so i can see
colts over there
see they're off looking
this map in particular has like
a lot of um oh i've got the same bloody
weapon
give me something good
um
[Music]
yeah so this map in particular has a lot
of like uh mines on it at certain times
of day
so colt um
can sometimes
be on a party just reveal his position
okay he's getting closer
[Applause]
so as juliana
especially with like
you get one shot especially when you
have like no weapons and no slabs the
slab it gave me was nexus so actually we
could try we could try and do a nexus
killing with like
a digger 4.0 that's fine
did i go i was gonna be tricking nexus
is rough to do it in pvp
i never use nexus in pvp like
the first couple times i played pvp i
ranked up because i
um
just like immensely lucked out
basically and i managed to kill
unnamed friend of ours three times
uh i managed to rank up quite
significantly from that and like do a
bunch of feats
but the thing with the multiplayer is
and like
i
first of all i play this game like it's
dishonored i don't play it like a first
person shooter but also the first time
you even see anyone you kind of freak
out and you're like
i have to do the same like get caught in
a very specific way and i have to kill
him and i have to get him
before and i just freak out and so
the ones the ones that are really good
i've played a few matches as juno i
think i'm like level
rank
11 or so maybe more on my other account
which is very much uh
my girlfriend lives in canada you don't
know she goes to a different school um
but it's like the ones that i've really
enjoyed are the ones where i have more
powers and i set up traps
which is a very very fun thing to do
because cults
just kind of are like oh they think
they've got the the high ground they
think they've got all the powers and
stuff um
it said connecting there but i don't
know if it did a countdown so this will
be interesting
this one is one of my favorite maps to
uh
[Music]
it said connected but then it didn't do
the countdown which made me think that
it wasn't gonna
go through
[Music]
so fake out
all right
tim how long do you want to keep going
we've probably got uh
what do we have
about six minutes left i was gonna say i
take i technically have a meeting at
nine slash yep stop saying
so let's make this our last invasion i
know we didn't get to spend much time
uh in the multiplayer maybe we could do
a separate pvp stream if there's enough
demand for it if there is demand yeah
like a more tricked out juliana it would
be very very cool um
but i think i'm going to stream this on
my
personal twitch so
uh i'm at lucy james games if you want
to follow me on there guess if i can do
it tonight if not definitely tomorrow
um hopefully there'll be more cults
online
to invade
um time are you gonna stream this one
i'm gonna stream this game yeah i think
i'm coming to the end of my uh
i've pretty much done with um
out wilds i streamed that on twitter tv
full slash and more h
um but
i think uh as a pallet cleanser game i
might go to um death loop and play a bit
of that
stealth your way through
let me try
abandon your meeting is what people say
jennifer heart says abandon me
sadly not
i mean
work must go on
that's yeah that's a frustrating thing
because we would have been on earlier
today but just like there has been a
myriad of tech issues so now it's all
set up though
so
we could just stream it later on it'll
be a laugh
[Music]
come on
be online
come on let me find someone
[Music]
nah it's not gonna happen don't think so
it's not so we might as well just wrap
it up now sadly
thank you everyone for watching for
watching this
early gameplay stream of death loop we
did a pretty good job of uh blingtay
says uh k
probably it wasn't no it was just like
tay uh
our glorious good point
gloria stream league stream lead uh
manager of video production
uh you should have seen the messages
that i was sending to tam this morning
where i just couldn't get obs to work so
this has just been a day of like tech
issues it is the 13th so maybe that's
something to do yeah but we appreciate
you waking up early and helping us out
with this so and the and the folks are
watching got a nice look at the early
game there was a very basic everything
that was streamed there was this kind of
stuff that's very
non-spoilery stuff that you will find in
the first early game and all the good
stuff it is uh still very very much
intact the surprises are intact but you
should have got a good feel for um how
to play the game mechanically and we all
answered a bunch of questions
um about how it plays if you wanna see
uh our deeper deeper impressions you can
check out uh the video review on
gamespot's youtube channel or go to
gamespot.com and read our written review
which was written by me i gave it a 10
out of 10 score which means it's
essential
um
one final person john reds uh thank you
for your comment you are getting banned
bro oh my god i was like i got no time
for gamer [ __ ] in the chat goodbye
um yeah everyone else for behaving
yourself
i would suggest going to a gamestop.com
reading times review it is truly
fantastic
i'm i did the video review and if you
kind of wanted to go wanting to go into
it um
i tried to only use footage from like
those first couple of missions so
if there's any footage of me using like
later like more stronger powers or
anything it's typically very spoiler
free um but yeah check that out
youtube.comgamesportgazer.com
i'm gonna be streaming this i will say
on my twitter when uh i'm on twitter
lucy james games twitch.com twitter tv
slash these games games as well tam
i'm on twitter at tomorrow h and on
twitch at twitch.tv for slash tomorrow h
alright thanks for watching everyone
goodbye